I've been using the ultra for one month
now and it's a great device but I wish I
could return it and it's not because
it's past the return policy which yeah
it is but it's because of multiple
usability issues Vadim reviewed the
ultra after one week of use and gave it
a raving review and I shot a bunch of
sweet Bureau shots for that which I'll
also share and use in this video but my
experience has been a bit different
because my review is not for those who
honestly just want to buy the Apple
watch Ultra for one simple reason it's
freaking cool now I completely agree
with pretty much everything that Vadim
said this was the most excited I have
been for an Apple Watch in many years
and even though I would have preferred a
square watch more like the leagues the
design is fresh and modern it is sporty
it looks industrial I do love that flat
top display and the crown guard also
looks industrial and it really minimize
how much fall Siri activations I got
when I'm having my hands on the ground
pushing against something I don't really
like the color of the action button but
it is very very useful to have I also
really like how loud and clear the
speakers are they are really really nice
for calls both for me to hear whoever
I'm talking to as well as for them to
hear me with those microphones now in
our Hands-On with the series 8 the
series 8 microphones actually sounded
better go ahead and take a listen this
is the microphone quality of the Apple
Watch series 8 and this is the quality
of the Ultras three microphones in a
room that doesn't have too much noise
now that is because the ultra chooses
which one of the three microphones to
use and here in our office it's not very
loud so I don't know what they chose but
in loud environments the ultra does a
better job now I also absolutely love
the haptics that are in this watch even
after a month I'm still surprised when
it goes and vibrates and notifies me how
much I feel that I can't miss it and
other people still don't hear that
vibration the red mode that is exclusive
to the ultra is also sweet and I use it
at night not to just save battery which
it does but because it is less
distracting now as far as a battery life
it is insane but I'll get back to that
in just a bit the new 2000 hits of
brightness on the display is also great
now I never complained about my previous
watches but it is nice to have in the
bright Sun now with that I do not love
the Alpine Loop now it holds really
great once you have it on but it's a
pain to put on it also can hit the
actual display in the body if you're
taking it off and putting it on a
charger and it's not that comfortable
after a while especially if that gets
wet now I also bought the diving Loop
but I don't really like using it either
now of course the Summer's kind of gone
so we're not swimming and boating as
much but for regular use putting it on
and off is a pain and I think that the
white also pops way too much compared to
the color of the watch so it's kind of
just sitting there don't get me wrong
both designs are great and they hold on
very well so they're doing what they're
designed to do but the Trail Loop sold
out instantly and even now the black and
gray one is still sold out so I can't
get one of them I'm still waiting on it
now I've tried a few third-party watch
bands and those aren't too bad but
because of the ultra being so tall it
basically makes the watch bands go
straight down if they're rubber or
different material and then you have
this Gap in between compared to you know
regular Apple watches where this pataka
carbon just wraps around so nicely it's
so lightweight and comfortable so
overall I just wish maybe we had more
choices from Apple now some people
complained about the price tag of 800
but my stainless steel with Milanese
Loop was 850 which now dropped in price
a bit so those are people who went out
and bought watches like this because
they are a lot more durable they will
not have an issue with the price now I'm
pretty hard on my watches and my
stainless steel one looks great compared
to my aluminum which dings and scratch
is super easy and the ion X glass which
sounds durable also scratches super easy
compared to the sapphire screen of the
stainless steel the ultra also has that
but because of the raised lip design
it's even more durable just watch Tech
racks smashing it with the hammer on his
desk and his desk breaks before the
watch does and even the internal parts
break before the screen cracks in the
last month I have slammed this thing
against doors and other objects with not
a single scratch or ding so it's
incredibly durable and the battery life
is tremendous even without the low power
mode which they showed off which is
going to give you like 60 hours of use I
finish off each day a normal day with
about 70 battery life remaining this is
something that Apple watch users have
been dreaming of for a long time now the
series 7 and 8 would still have good
battery life remaining at the end of the
day enough to do sleeve tracking and
then charge it in the morning but of
course that is with a brand new watch my
stainless steel now dies each day before
I go to bed which sucks and it is only a
few years old so the ultra will still
have great battery life even four to
five years from now which is another
great selling point now when I go out on
Long hikes the ultra can track my whole
day whereas I've had other ones die
before I am done so what do I not like
about it and why do I wish that I could
return it well one thing is Comfort I'm
used to the large size now it took about
a week and it's funny that the regular
watches feel small on my wrist now
overall it is less comfortable because
it is not only larger but also a lot
thicker so depending on what you're
wearing you know some longer shirts and
jackets they have a tough time slipping
over this watch and it really pops out
but another thing is sleep tracking now
I tried it out because the battery life
is great where my older one wasn't that
good and I cannot get used to it rolling
around in bed which I do I constantly
feel this thing now if that sounds funny
to you and like not a big deal MKBHD
actually switches out his watch band
each night and then again each morning
on his series seven just to get more
comfort for sleep tracking because of
that I'm not using this for sleep
tracking even though it seems like the
perfect device with great battery life
and the older watches were just so much
sleeker not only for sleep tracking but
just how they look on your wrist and
each time I grab this series eight with
this pataka watch band and I put it on I
just think man I wish that I could be
wearing that all the time this thing
just feels amazing on the hand
lightweight sleek and with that comes
looks now when I'm wearing an outfit
like this or with a jacket it looks
great it fits that normal kind of sporty
styling a t-shirt whatever but with
nicer looking clothes it just looks off
now I care about looks and the stainless
steel watches looked great with pretty
much anything that you wear especially
you know the gold one or you know any of
the other colors depending on what you
like because of this the ultra is
actually the watch that I've taken off
the most because it just doesn't look
good with a lot of things that I wear
now I really wish that this watch looked
a little bit less sporty like the leaks
we had for it and the Apple gave it
multiple color choices now sure keep the
plain Titanium because it's unpainted
it's the most durable but if Apple gave
us some options that would be really
nice the same thing goes with the size
now it's not too big for me and I got
used to it but for many other people it
just is and some people have returned it
because of that and honestly if Apple
could just give us better battery life
in a normal Apple watch which has a
lower price point that would be amazing
even if they had to cut out some of the
features to put in better battery life
now I know they talked about adding a
low power mode later but so many things
get shut off just take a look at this
list including getting text until you
actually press and turn on the watch to
get it to connect so from that point it
really doesn't make sense and it kind of
defeats the purpose of an Apple Watch
just to get better battery life so even
though I am using the ultra less than I
did my previous watches and I wish I
could return it the features and the
battery life just make it worth having
and I know that if I kept the series 8
and I use that instead there'd be many
times where I'd regret not having the
ultra so what I figured out that I'm
gonna do is keep my older gold stainless
steel watch because at this point I
looked up the resale value and it is
terrible and when I want a smart watch
and the ultra just doesn't look right I
will pop this thing on and use it and
that is a luxury I have as a tech
reviewer I already have the swatches
paid off but a lot of people don't have
that luxury so let's just hope that next
year the ultra will have other colors
than just the titanium and a smaller
size and just better battery life in
general for the normal Apple watches so
there you guys go that is my reasoning I
love this thing but there's always times
where I don't love it so much go ahead
and click that Circle above if you guys
want to see more videos check out
vadim's review right over there that's
been Max and I'll see you in the next
one
foreign